yeah hello and welcome to see your plane
victory 16 from Australia yes someone
recently explained how the New Zealand
like is differing they're all ready for
college okay so H for those only lines
are fairly interesting with the quick
each poem push like I just decided to
ignore it interesting of course you can
try to ignore it maybe i can bring the
Queen over immediately to h4 not sure
about threatening something I mean maybe
H takes H take screen h8 that there is a
threat but nobody falls for that one
okay so he moves his queen I would yeah
now if I take and then the cream SEC is
definitely a bogus Bishop takes c3 is
it's on the agenda actually on the
agenda
I take that insect the coin is that is
that completely ridiculous and my pieces
are not act as another to justify to
justify that how do I actually develop
here should take c3 the a bishop to be
too looks very very strange
[Music]
what a weird position the a queen age
form probably wasn't the greatest idea
ever what's that now can take and it
gets to take with the f porn htx krina
jake is made you so ok that is certainly
helpful the foursquare is something that
my queen likes to occupy maybe i can
trade those bishops and then put the
Queen on 34 and the really nice square
this whole lung setup is extremely hyper
modern in nature so he attacks it to
this one etude also e to bed but be too
mostly my bishop was hanging long
actually threatening see form winning
material Queen takes Bishop g7 ok I'm
not willing material by the way you can
move the queen of course m and then I
pinned my own Bishop c4 c4 Queen moves
it's not quite working
it kills okay can't play it just
strategically covering also the rock and
the queen is good only for yeah it's a
really good square and threatening see
for now cause it's a nice an additional
point then don't know 94 is probably not
good yet after Bishop see one there is
no good Queen move so yeah but this is a
this is a good position i will leave
from me I just need to get in d3 here he
wants to go Group A four is good
actually I can also put the hook on to
you for this is also good I managed to
get there are 96 maybe 449 f5 can still
go to you for me
maybe you can repeat them with 96 okay
with if he trades bishops I also have
the e5 square for the light and
protection suite okay ah now we can take
c4k it's not a big deal I didn't see it
didn't see it before hand
yeah they're basically horse all pawns
are hanging g5 is also up for grabs
[Music]
I'd like to go to you for to secure
everything and energy 45 and so on okay
I maybe I should have done that
differently but ok it is it is a it is
ok yeah it's nothing wrong with this
position time morning
okay forgotten about this one now he's
got a five which looks a little bit all
little bit annoying
can a 4 is made now do I stop this porn
case was a way to to stop it
okay 683 antica this is a very safe way
to take the pawn black realize okay okay
so that was interesting I think that
this is probably not great yeah this
opening results but I got a pretty good
position quickly afterwards and so we
went here yeah this is really annoying
bishops III the move Bishop e2 is not
really something I love to do which I
probably had turn now and points out
this move that would have been a draw
and this is helpful because now I can
take and yeah I mean earlier here if I
take he takes with the age opponent yeah
I briefly look at this because I mean
the king is a little bit of only seven
but I just don't have peace enough
pieces out yet I mean if I had to take
two extra move d3 Bishop d2 or something
then maybe you can do something there
this doesn't work and now he couldn't
take with the age for because this is
just check mate can't wait and after
ever takes oops after F takes and I've
gotten I got the square this is why I'm
training the light squared Bishop so
that i can use this better yell be one
intending intending as you fought the
right moment now we'll just go to you
for and now i'm covering this and c4 is
an idea and I think here I mean I'm
really surprised that the engine gives
us a sequel I mean it probably see some
see some concrete solution otherwise why
is just better yet because of the
structure
yes and yeah he has one two three
islands and I just have to and the a
porn barely cowan said sadly attackable
so I have like being better it's just
wrong just wrong assessment by the
engine maybe it evaluates the night
Heidi or something on c4 I just get a
night only for and slowly push back like
back so I'm not sure yet about the the
rook situation so I am e five yeah so
probably the engine has some kind of
tactic some kind of dynamic thing going
that that's possible yeah and that this
is some that this is working and that
means that c4 was wrong okay if you
can't do that because here was really
happy about that looks it looks
excellent now just win material now with
white so if I deform if anything that
will fit in the solution yeah ok guys
thanks for watching